op está desafinado hoje isto são só
ninguém está perto de mim
as tristezas tuma em pó
ninguém se esquece noite ninguém quer
saber
o lado diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e o estrago chique leite
eo cab é um jogo 1 112 de base comentou
nós vamos ser um andador e é por isso
também que conhece o chefe ficou falei
que na boca qual é o objeto investiu
perguntam vocês mas como nós somos um
moedor que temos de encontrar aqui uma
função para sair deste lago pelo menos
foi o que o percebido de ver alguns
vídeos também mexe eu já sei que o
bueiro está fechado porque já tinha
visto isso em algum lado
mas é isso não tem muito mais do que
isso por isso vamos lá tentar encontrar
qualquer coisa parecida que eu posso
curtir esta árvore posso que um enxame
de abelhas no motorista porque eu já sei
que é um baita carnê
nem chegamos longe quanto este picchu
patrimônio
o havaiano nenhum curso traz é evidente
que era também é esperado como eu sou eu
não consigo entrar aqui joga amanhã cá e
vamos tentar ver as outras casas de
acompanhar uma chata só tem 15 não
porque eu sei que este o grande terror
por isso por ser aqui tava ali uma
tamanha na minha cama pode como é
possível este atrevimento do que uma
caixa ou não quer o número quer apanhar
a caixa não quer apanhar a caixa aí
agora que faz com isto é que o meu
guarda-chuva os processos e parte já
está a ficar a noite traz cursos feira
pelo advogado andré caminhado eu quero
comer o suco que isto possa estar aqui é
seguro cai tudo tranquilo
o juiz luís na etapa e possibilita que
briguei eu peguei numa roupa ou ruby
qualquer coisa que eu não sou a automega
não não não eu tenho toda a direita ou
da esquerda não estou bêbado só eu que
tenho uma casa de casa das informações é
algo assim eu sentei mali tipo é preciso
meu cara só consigo ligar isto porque o
dá pra perder o que aprendi aqui
não quer deitar o meu pai é isto que fez
nenhum gol
é um só com os binóculos ou alguma coisa
assim lá na apanha o viaduto será que eu
tenho que apanhar um fiasco shot gun e
fazer alguma coisa com o enviado não
sair posso esperar pra aí
deste modo o cacau ou que é o que o
sangue deu o sangue na água mesmo que
aquilo que alguém morreu ficado envolver
outro lado da via está em alguma pista
assim obter o que inês rock o que
consegui fazer algo novo eu consegui
curtir o fio do uso de uma máquina que
está aqui eu não sei agora que curtos e
com isto eles têm água que também tem
água já não corre como um monstro em
dois de sustá-lo tempo faz ou não tem
que apanhar machado para lavar choque
ela não vou só coloque não não dar
desculpas escondendo casos contento casa
pela pancada eu acho que estava ela
abriu a porta a porta na cara tá eu já
[Música]
não acontece nada
agora bom eu não tenho escapatória
eu estava no varal para a caverna dela
para comer happy rock eu tenho por ter
este fio esta garrafa não serve pra nada
isto me deixa bimba por isso ou por tila
e aqui tem água aqui tem uma coisa a
alguém o balde o paulo tem um país a
implementar nada enxoval ver aqui isso e
está também toca ele agora pega no valdo
e e manda abrir um soco nela parceira
esta caixa que tem o que é isto que é
isto não sair e fazer a galera fronteira
que não é pouca e já descobri uma coisa
nova manterão lenha nos fogões ou aquela
coisa mais sagrada a cheia de tomar da
causa não apenas do sul este jogo
estúpido que eu tenho que fazer aqui
mesmo
não sei agora para inovar dani o vulgar
me tirar por ali
vamos ver se resulta não faltou carinho
daquela espera isa exata nem eu vou
ficar uns em miami onde está montada e
vou lá buscar o volga e esperar enquanto
viajava foi apanhada parece um boi
menina que não é um diário que um boi
por ver o filho da mãe
[Música]
a bruxa parece eu sei que o passageiro
ela é muito caro ao morro
ae
a não perder uma machada o farnel eu já
fui eu quem a não entrar em que morreu o
que vamos comer na casa mas não vamos
cuidar da casa
o embarque se eu morrer aumenta se
quiser ganhar e não ganhar não vai ela
vai aprender não vai ela não parece que
vou tentar sair só vou tentar o meu bebê
que ela espera ter agora a marca de água
vamos ver se resulta agora no golfo a
não se aborreça morreu o pai mata ela
não morre o amor meu pelo menos já fiz
uma coisa nova uma nova taxa
[Música]
ela tinha uma foto que englobam briga
dentro dela que mato - como é que vai
ser possível passar este o meu ok
pessoal já no seu jardim esperança
bruce caiu na minha armadilha aytac
profa
vamos tentar agora mataram briga dela
com uma chapa só agora lá anos
isso ofende choque elétrico na mesma
chave e agora vamos tentar montar aqui o
bicho mas chegando agora bota esses
qualquer pessoa honesta
agora vou conseguir matar ela more meu é
invencível é invencível tenho pra que a
transmil agora só agora vamos aproveitar
ae não é muito comum
braga isso mas conseguir as coisas que o
que agora pronto até estou salvo da
bruxa e agora que eu faço agora tem que
ir pra cama né
eu vou ganhar mais chato saber como é
que uma dessa [ __ ] web será que eu
tenho queimá lo aqui dentro eu já não
tenho madeira traz ainda meu já edu bill
[Música]
ganhou um carro
o vovô não falou com nenhum em posar com
esta [ __ ]
a foto em que aparece uma briga
ela vai saltar dados só puxa salto já
espera pela morte da filha da mãe da
tenista
o boca que costa a costa cruzeiro estava
0 x mil o que consegui matar
finalmente consegui passar este jogo é
tudo isso ao preço de uma porca é mas é
isso só vamos ficar porque com isto lake
view km eu acho que é assim que se chama
se quiserem ver mais jogos destes
símbolos de digão nem nos comentários ou
então ninguém mesmo um jogo específico
possa ser um verão deixa o nosso leque
fabri e favorito neste mostrar que é
favorito para apoiar porque isso ajuda
mesmo muito a zé mané japão em punho ele
desculpa eu sei caxito mabubas e é isso
fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]